for the third weekend in a row cries of
anger
and frustration echo across the city of
kabarosk
[Applause]
the arrest of their governor sergey
fergal has triggered the biggest
demonstration this region has seen in
years
the fifth-year-old member of the
opposition liberal democratic party was
detained earlier this month
he's charged with ordering the murders
and attempted murders of several
businessmen
15 years ago but many here see the
arrest as politically motivated
retaliation for defeating president
putin's favorite in the 2018
gubernatorial election
people are offended i think people take
to the streets because their vote in the
gubernatorial
but these protests are about more than
the arrest of their governor
it's about fighting back against what
they see as president putin's
increasingly authoritarian grip on power
with chance of freedom and putin is a
thief the protests have become a battle
cry of freedom
freedom from the rulers sitting more
than 6 000 kilometers away in moscow
whom they see is self-serving and out of
touch
[Music]
moscow is sucking up all the resources
from the far east and we get nothing in
return
this region used to be so rich the
people were doing so well
and the production was thriving now all
the big enterprises have been bought up
by moscowitz
[Music]
putin's appointment of a successor has
not helped that's even though michelle
dictiorov
a member of the same party as furgal was
seen as an attempt by the kremlin
to assuage locals anger
but the people of kabarovsk have fired
back saying the 39 year old outsider
lacks experience
and has no connection to the region as
both sides stick in their heels
this standoff is likely to continue the
question is
how long the protesters can last
president putin is in no hurry
a constitutional change passed early
this month means he could stay in power
until 2036.
now earlier i spoke to ivan gershkovitz
in kavarov's covering that demonstration
i asked him how this protest was
different from others we'd seen in
russia
it's truly one of the most surprising
protests we've seen
in years in russia in all of putin's 20
years
one of the main things we've seen the
reason police aren't clearing the
streets is the mass
people that are coming out the first
protest that took place here three weeks
ago was 40
000 people a week later last saturday we
saw 50
000 and today estimates ran as much as
90 000. now to put that in perspective
there's
about 600 000 people who live in the
city of cabotix so it's like ten percent
of the city is coming up to protest
there's also a notion that the kremlin
is hoping that this will simmer down
but as we're seeing three weeks in it's
only growing so time will have to tell
whether the kremlin will decide to crack
down or not but so far
they haven't not sure whether you've
been in a position to do much reporting
literally down
on the streets there but what are the
protesters saying is compelling them to
get on the streets in defiance of what's
the natural order there in russia
there's a lot of different slogans that
are being screamed about you know the
governor specifically
to anti-kremlin sentiment but the main
thing that the protesters have repeated
day after day these rallies to
no continue each day but the main ones
happen on saturday
is that they feel that their choice was
taken away they feel that even if their
governor is guilty of these crimes
he should be uh tried here in cabarets
they believe they voted for him they
feel that moscow the kremlin has now
taken
him away for political reasons not
reasons that
uh they believed to be fair because
these murders were if these alleged
murders were 15 years ago so if they did
take place they believe that the kremlin
would have dug this up
a long time ago and so they believe that
their choice was stolen away
and so at the end of the day it's about
a right to a fair choice it's about
called a democracy it seems
you